welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage
yeah it is it's a little shall we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
found out they're going to be classy
just a big old piece of trash trash i'm
your host state trolley down here at
aunt toddy's basement she's upstairs
cutting the lawn
trimming her pubes
do it in the backyard i told her knock
that [ __ ] off
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me unamused
i went for it i apologize
i pushed the envelopes of my twitty's
intros he is the ceo of are you garbage
he's international businessman and i'll
tell you what else on the low he's my
best pal in the whole wide world and i
love him
give it up for kevin james ryan thanks
pal love you too big man thanks for
tuning in everybody please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube as you know those
numbers are true the roof cooking
then obviously patreon.com you sign up
there you get a whole [ __ ] ton of
content i think a bajillion hours we
just hit it's good stuff check it out
patreon.com backslash are you garbage i
think any slash is fine did they get rid
of that just google it
google it
this kid's pretty smart how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer i
haven't understood any of the choices
you've made so far
i mean we typically work well as a team
you're out in the left field with a
hockey stick i'm not going to deny that
they've all been missteps i'll give you
that
i'm hoping to land this plane and right
this ship
let's see how the toby throw goes gang
up in a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good we love them you
love them give it up for t-bone
mcbuttons toby mcmullen what up dudes
hey t-bone i want to let all the
listeners out there know we got a rad
dad in the studio
and i'm taking all bets on whose kid is
gonna double backflip first mike cannon
versus tim butterly versus jeremiah
watkins my money's on cannon baby
we got a little family in the building
right here he's a family member at this
point he's a family man very funny
another get the guns out boys
we had a [ __ ] old shootout down yeah
you're coming over a nice time wow you
asked me to put on my glasses for this
i'll punch you man in glasses
i'm all screwballs and he's taking shots
at you
yeah he's got a brand new special out
right now called white privilege home is
homeless you can check that out on his
youtube page check it out give it up for
the one the only mr mike kennedy yeah
how you doing everybody uh my money's on
butter lee's kid for sure they they they
feel like they're just already doing
front flips yeah and somersaults they're
upside down people they also get some
years on my kid you know he's more into
he's more into dunking yeah one of those
kids one of his kids are gonna become
nightwing or something like that dude
right a grayson yeah can i be honest
with you yes my money's unbutterly but
we got too much money on that side so
i'm trying to get some money on your
side i appreciate it dude thank you
thank you
does the little guy have a bike did you
get him a little bmx plus he's got a
he's got one of those balance bikes
okay so he's he's with training wheels
no no
no
no nothing yeah just kind of [ __ ]
it's like a scooter that you sit on kind
of huh that makes sense it's a bicycle
but yeah it's two wheels and you just
kind of cruise it's like if the
flintstones car was a bike you know so
there's no pedals you're just kind of
like learning to stabilize yourself but
kids basically like rip on these things
on dirt tracks so i'm looking for i'm
like shoving them down steep hills see
what he's made of dude
you know what's crazy i've seen these
kids on those goddamn scooters
you see like a toddler like ripping down
like [ __ ] fifth avenue yeah i'm like
wait how did you [ __ ] i was a big
wheel kid when i was two my son is two
he hadn't had a big wheel i don't know
if they even sell them for less than
like six grand on ebay because
everything vintage they don't have them
now they don't they're not still making
it i don't think not the plastic ones
yeah the plastic ones that get the hole
in the wheel well yeah the hold the
wheel you'd go to fix it you're two and
you'd slice an order but you had to have
those plastic wheels because you
couldn't drift if you didn't have that
that's right
yeah so whatever that big front wheel
like a new pair of shoes
i mean this is how little parents used
to or at least mine gave a [ __ ] i was
two years old i couldn't imagine even
allowing my son out of my sight he's so
incapable of surviving and i was like
going down hills at two and a half years
old on my big wheel so much so that
while drifting at the bottom i skidded
out on gravel and face planet
on the street and carved up the entire
right side of my face like hopefully it
does happen in background it didn't i i
specifically remember riding my big
wheel going down the middle of our
street on our in our development and
also too i remember like the first time
i discovered like tar like what they put
on the street like you know that the
sealant that they put on it was like a
summer it was like a summer i remember
the smell and then i looked back and
realized like oh i was sitting in the
middle of the road playing with [ __ ]
wet tar
like that's [ __ ] insane some of the
best days of my life
it was though and now you're sucking it
into your lungs
i started at a young age i remember the
first time i got a proper bike my mom
was like we'll go we like went and got
me a bike like no trains wheels i don't
remember i was young i just remember it
was green yeah and i remember my bike i
was like
all right
my driveway you go head first nerd
and then i'm gonna tail whip right over
you
you tell your non-gt pro performer story
i did have some nice bikes but the first
one i was like probably six or whatever
i don't know i didn't know how to ride a
bike without training wheels yeah and my
mom was like yeah let's just single
mother you know she was like all right
let's [ __ ] try
so i'm like all right and she just i
remember being like this i remember i
can still feel nervous i'm like this
isn't gonna be good
and i was like all right so i just get
on the bike and i we go i'm going my
driveway is a hill so i pick up enough
momentum to where i'm like i don't need
to balance right the bike's balancing
it's them
and dude i just i don't i didn't know
what to do i didn't know anything i
didn't know brakes or anything i just
[ __ ] went and hit the [ __ ] curb
and did a front did a front flip over
and just like wind knocked out of you at
five years old i was like
yeah you hit the brain i mean how the
[ __ ] going on lady that feels like i'm
operating this way that feeling
that feeling is the exact same feeling
an adult would feel if they were like
pushed off a building 100 because you
have no concept of how to stop no you
think it's life or death there's nothing
to stop you from smashing your soft head
into the pavement which was precisely
what happened insane i learned how to
ride a two-wheeler when i was four years
old my parents took me and my older
sister on vacation to amish country to
lancaster pennsylvania yeah two-wheeler
field trip like without without training
oh okay so i had like a huffy training
wheel whatever that i was like taking
off of rocks and insane because i was a
nuts kid i just had so much energy i was
just smashing into [ __ ] oh you're a calm
guy
i've smoked myself into submission
but i could still you know i could i
could peak at times
that is exactly right dude that's how it
is it's like my little stress monkey
otherwise he jumps off roofs in the
pools i can't stop
i think i can clear the gap what dude
relax
hit the joint will you
oh you're right yeah i probably
shouldn't climb the roof
we're on an airplane you're like i'm
gonna climb down through the wheel
all right could just wait for the jet
way
hey take an edible relax
otherwise you turn into bear grylls
you know i don't know i just have too
much testosterone
uh but so i learned some older kid in
amish country was like living and
actually subsisting on that farm that we
stayed on and vacationed on and he
taught me how to ride it in the grass to
the point where i got confidence i was
obsessed with this movie rad which i've
since named my son after the lead
character and uh it was just like
everything to me so my parents my first
bike they it was the last present of
christmas it's like the one christmas
that they absolutely knocked out of the
park and they've been eating off that
forever how old are you remember
how old are we at this point i'm four
you're four i'm four yeah jesus going on
five so i'm like i'm closer to five than
i am to four but i was like i was riding
and ripping all over the huffy got like
what are you supposed to say
at four are you i think so right that's
normal
i don't know i don't have children yeah
that's about when i got mine really i
mean my sister was like 11 but she's the
least athletic human being on earth my
dog is five months
but so my parents it was like the one
christmas they they crushed they put it
over or under this blanket and i
remember just shaking tearing it off and
it was a mongoose m1 1989
and it was like the sickest bike
straight from the you know
hungoves was the big thing undergrad so
i was just like it was [ __ ] the
greatest gift of mine it was a little
one though for a little for a little a
smaller kid it wasn't like a full-size
like bike was it yeah i mean it was
probably like it's probably a junior
size i guess it was i mean in my mind
now i'm considering it full size but i
don't know it must have been like a
junior yeah i guess i mean you're
shattering my perspective and my you
were
yeah but i was riding i don't know i was
riding all the older kids bikes too if
you slam that seat to the bot to the
bottom bmx bikes are super small as is
damn yeah yeah no i think it was
how long did you keep that bike for with
how long was that your bike that was my
bike probably until i was like
12.
yeah so then i got a uh a dino nsx i
believe which is actually a downgrade
and a shittier racing bike but i i took
that through hell i i [ __ ] i'd like
lit m80s off of that thing it was just a
[ __ ] lunatic we used to have we used
to build like dirt ramps yeah and use
doubles and like use logs to build it up
and then slam the mud on top of it and
like really shape this [ __ ] dude and i
like i mean i stopped once i started
getting hurt and i liked basketball
better but i like tried to tabletop and
do 360s and i'd smash into a birch tree
an exception is that what they were
called x or somewhere you would do that
right x up yeah remember like justin's
going to try and x up we're like wow
call the news will ya and there's no
youtube videos to teach you how to do
any of it so nobody's saying like lead
with your head turn and trust in god you
would just see it on a like
skating videos were bigger like bmx
videos and stuff like that we would
watch that and be like oh let's [ __ ]
go try this let's try it
you were like you were like evil knievel
you know evel knievel back in the day
was using just like a regular harley to
jump those things
now like not like a jump biker not
reinforced [ __ ] heavy bikes
that's pretty badass but yeah i mean
i'm no like i wasn't like that like i
wasn't you weren't dropping the grand
canyon yeah we picked up i wasn't
i wasn't jumping
super dave osbourne
[Laughter]
i was jumping three-foot dart jobs sure
they were i remember the one it was like
a table top and it was like the older
kids had made it i don't know you just
like you found them or somebody told you
and we went they were like abandoned and
this
in the woods you're talking yeah in the
woods and this table top in
like my perspective then yeah might as
well been 400 feet long i really like
this is the big like if i had if i was
probably describing it to somebody i'm
like dude it's [ __ ] 15 feet high we
get 35 feet in the air
it was probably this big
dude and then when i started playing
poker later in my life when i was like
19 we are very similar
suburban white trash yes
and when i played poker man myself so
and then i went back and i started
buying the things i had as a kid so i
bought this [ __ ] like 600 red line
that i wanted this insane bike and i was
building jumps i'm like 19 living at my
parents going to community college
playing basketball did you see the jump
i know i'm failing out building up the
jump building jumps in my backyard and
having no math ability or any like
engineering background all the wood's
gone from the dining room table
my shed is making a wall yeah you take
the leaf they've done that
taking the lead for the course ma dude
so i built this ramp and i'm super
pumped in my head this is the start of a
new life
the i i built it too abrupt didn't
consider needing the lift or anything
like that i'm like just look how high
i'm gonna go in the air and i just raced
towards this ramp
hit it as if it was a brick wall got
launched into the air bailed on the bike
landed with my foot on the peg and
sliced my entire ankle and i put that
bike in the shed and then never touched
it again you gotta bury it in the
backyard the kids that live there now
probably haven't
you guys
hey there's a half a box of cheerios in
here my family's carcass is in that
house
and i had to look at it every day while
i lived at my in-laws over the pandemic
[Laughter]
kids good news you're not going to wash
your dishes tonight
bad news just start packing
you got the spot now you got your own
place now yeah yeah now we have a house
how do you feel domestication wise um i
mean i'm still not like i'm not a man
because the jumps in the backyard aren't
done yet
i got a snack bar and everything dude
it is we're working on the trail
wiffle ball courts going up thursday
it's got the gate
[Laughter]
it's hot out of the shoe clean i think i
got this one that's right that's how my
kid will earn my love what's the what's
this what's the square footage out there
what do you got out there uh we have
like we have a three bedroom i don't
know i have no idea what the square
footage is
it's a it's a cute house there's a
little bit of a yard but there's so many
parks also nearby and okay
it's it's more about that but uh we were
judged not to cut you off we were just
talking about on over there on the
patreon on uh
hard feelings i would i'm becoming more
do you feel like more of a suburban guy
now now that you're out there and you're
out of the city a little bit you're like
oh i really appreciate it for what it
yeah i feel like like i grew up so i was
born here in the city and then i grew up
in the suburbs and everybody that grows
up in the suburbs resents the suburbs of
course so i then moved here
lived here thought this was my defining
characteristic that i lived here and
then i moved out there and i was like i
like this yeah that's where this is
weird this is weird that i like this and
i also am am spoiled in the sense that i
get to come in every single day so i'm
like a heroin addict that's just
chipping at new york city getting my
little your needs yeah get what i need
where's the closest dollar slice place
yeah getting jerked off on and then i'm
out and then i'm right back over the
bridge who's cut in the yard though not
me no that's the thing i don't i don't
know if i can own a house my money is on
no but i would i mean or until i could
just hire everybody to do what my father
could do okay you know what i mean so if
something breaks you don't think you can
you wouldn't be able to handle it or
anything like that like unless unless it
needs to be broken like unless i need to
like break it into being fit it's
halfway broken i can smash it if you
want me to
do you know how to fix [ __ ]
not really i got i could get away with
it i can get away with some stuff
nothing electrical like what so i can
get away with some stuff so i can build
like this yeah you know what i mean i
could build a bed frame sure i could
follow
that's right that's exactly right so all
of my son's toys damn it where's g4 the
toys come on [ __ ] you and the toys come
on the toys are are like an engineering
nightmare they are a true problem that
should be on the blackboard in goodwill
hunting it's insane dude
insane everything's so small i'm a shaky
sweaty [ __ ]
yeah i'm not good i can hang some stuff
but i don't do it well and then my what
it's not it's up to my standard i'm like
i'll get whatever you want i'll hang the
curtains the whatever i'll do all that
stuff i'll set the anchors i can do it
but like
oh so you can mount the tv
i can mount this yeah but then i just
got it i'm not the one on my room yeah
my wife
yeah i did i did the one at my old
apartment i found the job i did and then
hired to ask gravity that's where i'm at
now yeah we got a guy who lives in the
building who does like all the handiwork
i go just [ __ ] call him i'll give him
20 bucks yeah and he's [ __ ] he shows
up drunk gets the job done about five
hours
he comes up with nothing and i'm like he
goes what are we doing we gotta hang the
tv he goes all right and he comes back
in with like no tools he's like i gotta
go back get down but what are we doing
15 times i can cut some wood i can uh i
can clock the bathroom i could do [ __ ]
like that
i worked construction so i've done it
before like i i i roofed i did all that
[ __ ] i helped i i'm a good helper and
assistant but i don't have any [ __ ] out
of a flashlight of any knowledge you
need somebody to run and get sandwiches
i'm your guy i am the best at that it
was the lead nail board dude i worked
construction and after two weeks he put
me on filing
the office with the ladies
he was like you know what you'd do i
have an office it's kept like a like a
crypt he's like just figure out how to
make this like hospitable and i did yeah
so i was his woman
i was gonna blow me around lunchtime
wear a skirt tomorrow
we're gonna be going out of boca this
weekend
gang this podcast is sponsored by better
help
guys you gotta remember one thing what's
that bud you're a bozo uh-huh second
thing you want to remember your most
important relationship that you have
with anybody on this planet is with
yourself and you got to take care of
yourself you feel a little overwhelmed
you're feeling a little run down do
yourself a favor get on the horn there
and reach out to better health because
they can't help yes if you're feeling
burnt out lack of motivation helpless or
trapped detachment fatigue or more
better help uh online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself you
know what i mean
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to look at that it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and can be matched with and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours which is very
convenient if you have never gotten into
the therapy pool it is very hard to find
and schedule yourself as we know your
first uh
appointment
48 hours is unheard of it's fantastic
are you garbage listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp.com garbage
b-e-t-t-h-e-l-p
dot com
garbage do it do it let's talk about
ladder ladder let's talk about ladder
gang don't forget how fragile life is we
almost found that out in an suv on the
highways of phoenix on our life you
would have left the
left your family holding a bag holding
the [ __ ] empty bag of weed i could
tell you that
smoke my [ __ ] but gang do yourself a
favor do your family a favor you don't
want to leave them hanging out in the
lurch nope you don't want to be [ __ ]
buried in the backyard in a goddamn
refrigerator box so get yourself some
term life and talk to the good people at
ladder to straighten you out cue ball
let them know what they got to do ladder
is 100 digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for 3 million
in coverage or less just a few questions
about your health on the application
tell them the bald guy sent you i don't
know why you're doubling down on that
you just need a few minutes on the phone
or laptop to apply ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved no
hidden fees canceled at any time full
refund if you change your mind in the
first 30 days
uh finally since life insurance cost
more as you age now is the time to cross
it off your list so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com
ah good stuff buddy congratulations on
the [ __ ] special congrats thanks
everybody check it out mikey is a killer
killer killer killer check it out let's
do some cues here as you know you sign
up for the patreon we'll answer your
question on the air we have the great
mike cannon here with us today for all
that
um all right this one is from let me get
a bernie which i didn't it took me a
while to pick up on that i thought his
name was really lemmy
um
this is have you or anyone in your
family ever saved the watermark school
photos instead of paying for them
that's real bad for sure yeah yeah 100
there's like i remember seeing one later
on in life of being like oh
we just kept this one just think about
it like mark's photography or oh
screwing that guy over just think he had
a [ __ ] deal with that yeah small
business owner 80s 90s just getting
ripped off by dirk bag moms i'm sure a
majority of the kids didn't get them
there was also a couple pictures where
my mom like to my face said i don't like
how you look so i'll just i'm not going
to pay for these it's your face yeah
she's like
why'd you smile like that
i'm like she anna wintour what the [ __ ]
yeah she just didn't care for the face
she created so my god
told you to turn to the left yeah i'm
not paying for this chin down and out i
told you you needed braces
[Laughter]
you've been talking to my mom jesus
christ
i remember i went over my dad's in my
20s my parents separated him in my i was
in college or and the last picture he
had of me on the mantel was from fourth
grade
and you were in the background
it was up to two friends at a bar
just in hysterics
which one which boy is yours i see the
kid in the back by the poker machine
blowing his eyes out i've never been
like take this on the golden t machine
it looks like i died
why i was talking to my homie about the
casino trip we did for the patreon video
and they told me that their parents used
to drop them off
at the daycare at the casino
oh yeah that makes sense that's good
business from a casino standpoint hey
we'll give you a free we'll give you a
free child what are you doing there i've
done you've got babies
right
yeah that's that's i mean it's the worst
timing of all time but i was like on
mushrooms smoking weed outside and
there's like 48 kids running in wet
bathing suits outside like chattering
from the 43 degree air conditioning
inside and just being like mom
brent and segalo and i are just like
out of jesus dude
you're out front meeting your guy
waiting to grab a bat
but your cold children run by
that's pretty trashy what the [ __ ] do
they do with the kids in there that is
nuts
just [ __ ] yeah mini pretzels and
[ __ ] the people's court
judge judy reruns
all right buddy so you want to split
aces
it's getting them hooked young they're
playing for animal crackers
uh some strung out go fish dealers
hanging out there watching
i just saw you posted a picture of your
son
uh just recently in the school picture
yeah yeah today and actually oh yeah you
were in it with him that's so i got i
hoodwinked them apparently because you
know my kid trying to get some headshots
i brought i brought two looks pieces
[ __ ] provencio was booked can you crop
him out huh
you make can you get one of me duncan or
something
can you make his head a basketball so
i'm holding it like that
so he was but i brought him you know to
school pictures and he's [ __ ] too
dude so as soon as you tell him to do
something he's like suck my dad i'm not
doing the opposite he's just a whirling
nervous just throwing [ __ ] so the only
way i could get him to kind of chill for
a picture was to take one with him and
then they thought i was a teacher so
they print out free copies for teachers
and they just printed it out gave it to
the teachers and they're like this is a
parent but
i guess we'll give it to him that's
great did you get a couple did he sit
for a couple by himself yeah but he
looks like he's on coke and all of them
he's like probably got into your bag
yeah he's just numbed up
but that also because you put him in a
you put him in a biggie smalls t-shirt
yeah sweatshirt and it really that it
blew my mind to something i never i
remember being so nervous about how you
look and what are you going to wear and
i like that like it doesn't like i
remember every year being like a panic
attack
it doesn't [ __ ] matter brutal that
picture back there there was a war over
what what i had to wear no the one back
there was my parents oh yeah i remember
what i mean that's like a that's a real
family
i was getting screamed at this that and
the other thing eve to going to school
you have to wear a nice shirt and die i
like that parents have loosened up with
that i will let the kids be comfortable
that's more i think stuff like that
still exists because my friends have
like
real kind of creepy weird or not even
friends but people all white on the
beach yeah it's so bizarre but i
remember wearing like a gray suit and a
red bow tie like like just a fresh
pedophile bait and having to like going
to some strange studio with my parents
and then just melting down on me and
then being like
it's [ __ ] there yeah dude
but yeah sweet though
you know i should reenact that for our
next door suspenders make it pop i know
that is
such a good idea what redo remake those
photos and we'll use them as promo
that's pretty good
i'm with it yeah i'm with it i mean i'm
sharp as [ __ ] in that one i don't give a
[ __ ] i'll grab a blue blazer and a
paisley tie
no problem
i'm not dressed like white urkel over
there in the corner
getting on your nerves today
no i was reading i was looking for a
next question i wasn't listening to you
and then you looked at me for a laugh to
be like right pal i'm like i wasn't i
was not checked into the program for a
minute well you're just a fan of the
show you missed
you missed a real doozy i can tell you
that yeah it seemed to kill in the room
i was getting the save me eyes quick
may day mayday
give me a pity laugh
that is something you pick up from your
fellow like from a co-host where you
where they get that life preserver
comedy raft
hello
[Laughter]
all right let's see this one we had
mentioned before but i'm curious to see
if you've ever done it uh ever this is
from bozo ever wash your shoes in the
washing machine or a hat in the
dishwasher yeah to both have the
dishwasher i didn't know you sell racks
for them yeah yeah it's like a rack you
put it in the molds i thought you would
put it in there why would you put it in
the dishwasher because it i don't know i
guess it's clean yeah just if you think
about it if there's no you don't do it
in there whatever [ __ ] lasagna dish
it's also only a certain like you could
have put it in fresh yeah but i put like
a new era hat in there and it blew the
back open like that the thing that keeps
it firm in the front it just like it put
that they never come out the same but
i've been seeing on like instagram and
tick tock people doing their shoes in
there and i'm like it looks like it
[ __ ] works it just it seems like it
would make everything wonky i do that
like i do the spray [ __ ] i don't throw
it in unless it's like a parrot converse
because it's canvas and that makes sense
but if it's like leather they're stinky
too you gotta get that oh dude i've i've
destroyed washing machines with like a
pair of british knights in the in the
early 90s dude when i my when i was a
kid my feet were like
truly a problem to the point where my
mom had to like talk to people when i
went over to visit and be like like if
he takes off his his shoes it's gonna be
oh it's gonna be rough for your carpet
so i don't know i'm doing a sleepover
with boots on
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
that cannon kid is real high strung
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
that's crazy dirt jumps and stinky feet
bro
[Laughter]
i wouldn't have let my mom tell anybody
don't [ __ ] call anybody i wouldn't
have went anywhere publicly ever yeah it
was rough kids that came with warnings
[Laughter]
my dad turned the ceiling fan on have
you bleached your feet have you ever
bleached them no yeah
i've soaked my feet in a tub of bleach
to rid them of smell before this is like
back in the day like when i was playing
sports and [ __ ] they're okay now did it
work i don't know now i'm okay no i
can't feel the bleach work at the time
yeah you know it made him smell like
something else i was just walking around
smelling like a slight gum
you pull your feet out it's just bones
all right set to go
it's just bones
that's wild yeah
he takes his shoes off stick him in a
thing of bleach
yikes
i feel like i'm bumming you guys out
i just never thought that's insane
bleach your feet
i like my bleach i have to bring it on
my third appearance
i gotta be invited back you know what i
mean
i gotta leave it all out of there
i can't steal your bathroom cake
shocking
[Laughter]
you guys ever dunk your head in
pneumonia
that's garbage right
that's probably what happened to your
hair
dude it is well i think this is like it
was always gray but i do think from
bleaching it during the pandemic it got
like that's right i forgot about it a
little whiter because i mean i had i
kept it tight for a long time and now
it's this and it's like oh this is way
different it looks great buddy i
appreciate it you're gorgeous it looks
sharp [ __ ] and i love the glasses thanks
pal you know trying to be a dad on
euphoria
that's it that's what i'm angling for
they put it out to the universe that's
like the third podcast i've mentioned
that
[Laughter]
sort of new headshots were for that's
right that's right
uh this one's from bozo the clown do you
know anyone who does a lot of side work
but hasn't had a real job in years
that's pretty good well one of my best
friends is a shaman
so yeah really yeah
i mean he's a spiritual journey
spiritual leader and guide
and and uh
yeah yeah he's the one actually that you
look you look a lot alike picture
all-american guy alpha male football
player he's
[Laughter]
full circle
but he does a lot in that world and i
don't i don't know exactly what he does
but that's his job yeah wow yeah we had
a couple one of my buddies dad's uh he
did like
he did painting but he worked like once
every two months he'd have like a
painting job for a couple of couple of
days and that would be it right it was
like little just little sporadic things
we're we're a very trade heavy family
all my uncles all in the trades all
their kids so like
at any given party or whatever there's
at least three guys not there because
they're doing side work right you're
like oh you're like you're like
[ __ ] where's mike at i picked up side
work he's taping someone's basement or
whatever you know yeah he's [ __ ] you
know
so many of our comedian friends are also
exactly this oh of course it's like
sometimes you just have to dip back into
that or whatever yeah yeah yeah but yeah
a lot of moving is a big one for combat
because you're like there's no like real
actual job hiring process it's like can
you be on the truck by 11.
all right you get your cash tomorrow
that is a brutal job i did that once
forever i don't even move myself i hate
it yeah no i hate i'm such a [ __ ] when
it comes to moving let me ask you this
so this was a sticking point with my
wife and i we moved during the pandemic
right and she hired a friend of hers but
he does like breakdown for her business
so he's like a moving type dude right so
we hired him and his buddies to come
move our and move our stuff i'm
listening my wife like the alpha half a
dude she is was like picking up boxes
with them and bringing them down to the
truck and like helping sure the entire
process i stayed in the truck
i stayed in the moving truck the entire
time because i paid them
did she give you [ __ ] about you staying
in the truck she she like was apparently
it's an issue yeah they moved a year ago
[Laughter]
well i but it's it's not a long-standing
issue but i am curious do you think that
that is like an insane thing to do
it definitely doesn't look great because
my wife's insistence on helping them
herself sure but sure my point is that
we paid for it one i i'm a big proponent
of that of like i thought you were gonna
say she volunteered you that's what
would have happened to me i would have
been volunteering to be on the crow
which i would have freaked out but she
knows
you need a guy to have a heart attack on
the second floor i am a petulant child
when it comes to manual labor i've done
it for enough of my life i no longer
want any part of it it's just not in the
cards so my point is with paying i just
i want to wash my hands of it that's the
entire thing i completely agree
on your side okay i would have i would
have taken it one step further i would
have yelled at my wife to be like
[ __ ] stop you're making me look like
an idiot
yeah yeah i melted
yeah it
it's like i threw a real tantrum you
showed her
hold on here's the question though was
there a deal on the
on the on the services or did they
charge full rate i'm sure there's i mean
i'm sure there was some sort of
whatever it was enough money where i
felt comfortable it wasn't like hey
she's coming over to hell it wasn't for
like 150 bucks okay and we'd like it was
yeah help us out yeah 100 yeah that's
why i'm doing i'm hiring you i don't
want to do it i don't like it i don't
like the steps yeah i remember that i
moved in probably almost two years ago
18 months ago or something like that in
the you know mid pandemic and uh
i it was the first time i ever paid for
a mover like we had made a couple of
bucks and it was like we were up at four
floor we're on our fourth floor walk up
and i'm like i'm not [ __ ] doing that
i'm me and my wife are gonna get
divorced
[ __ ] out of the living room you know
what i mean i'm like i'm not doing this
so this [ __ ] eastern european guy
came in and literally he's like what
goes i was like everything dude he put a
couch one guy put a couch on his back
and just went down i'm like yeah i paid
five thousand dollars and never have to
do that that's insane yeah it's the best
it's the best thing you can spend money
on they're like this is it i'm like yeah
this is it they were in and out in 12
minutes oh my god fantastic i had to i i
tried to move myself at one point and i
had a friend come over to get out of bed
had a friend come over and help me that
jokes haven't been hidden i got about
one trip and i was like [ __ ] this call
to moving company to have them come in
and and move us my god i'll be there
i'll be there in an hour
i completely dipped
my friend still was helping them move
all this [ __ ] i just hung upstairs and
organized everything yeah this year that
i had already gone through the packing
process dude that's enough of a
nightmare i'm just talking every time i
move i end up throwing away 80 of what i
yeah i understand why history has burned
books yeah like it's the worst [ __ ]
thing to move and haul in the i would
rather lose most of the education of
human beings than to [ __ ] move a
bookcase worth what are you doing that
sanskrit i'm not carrying that [ __ ]
a person a box of books is 4 000 pounds
king louie's bible torture i was a mover
for a while and we moved a guy who had a
box cardboard box full of bricks oh
brick collector
a bricklayer oh [ __ ] you you're a
[ __ ] yeah he was like from like
stadiums or something [ __ ] i've never
wanted to i still think about drowning
that
[Laughter]
yeah no way would i ever do that that's
[ __ ]
uh all right this one's from alex have
you or anyone in your family ever been
addicted to something that wasn't drugs
or alcohol my cousin ben has an
unhealthy addiction to final fantasy vi
online for ps2
nerd alert uh
yeah addicted to being a i remember my
buddy's friend addicted to being a
virgin
final fantasy that's like anime tough
yeah
my buddy's friend used to play his
younger brother we were like big into
bikes so we were like 15 14 or whatever
and he was like maybe 11 or 10 a couple
years younger than us and we'd be like
yo we're going down to the jumps like
every day in the summer and he would sit
in his room and play this game called
ashran's call and we would i've heard of
that game we would
destroy him like we would just [ __ ]
run in and i mean we were very mean
in hindsight uh just like unplug it dude
he would freak oh no
proper chemical addiction what the hell
are you [ __ ] thought like yeah lose
it there yeah
they would yell get the [ __ ] out of that
goddamn room
[ __ ] oh he was like the guy he was
like chris farley from the bears
get the [ __ ] out of that goddamn room up
there on a computer losing it
proper chemical addiction is a great way
to put it because i said you're addicted
to the dopamine you're addicted it's
it's you're not just like i like this
game i think there was a girl in fourth
grade that was addicted to eating
tissues oh yeah she ate something there
was that chick on tlc
no no
couches she would eat the foam products
yeah i've never had family members do i
all of my family members are addicted to
drugs and alcohol and alcohol and
emotional abuse but the normal stuff
yeah sideways
mobile mint mobile mint mobile baby 45
times fast
i bet you can't right now know what else
you can't do what can't overpay with
those guys sure they don't get you
jammed up
tell them kippy in a fatty cent yeah
this is what they do mint comes in they
see the middleman cut him out pass the
savings on to you what do they probably
charge though over there for a month
probably forty five fifty dollars a
hundred bucks fifteen bucks you [ __ ]
yeah
that's their secret sauce
that's what they know a little bit of
barbecue a little bit of secret sauce
all men mobile daddy touch it truffle
uh-huh uh for anyone who hates their
phone bill mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month i've
been saying this since they came on as
an advertiser my wife has been using it
for you the bird uses it it's fantastic
they send it right to your door it is
genuinely 15 bucks a month it's bananas
they give you the best rate uh whether
you're buying one for a family uh and
mint family started two lines that's
pretty good it's a small family it's
tight circle like i keep it all plans
come with unlimited talking text
high-speed data delivered right there on
the nation's largest 5g network use your
own phone keep your number and you're
not going to bamboozle you or nothing
switch to mint mobile you have a premium
wireless server starting at just 15
bucks a month then get your new wireless
plane listen here and listen good it's
15 bucks a month plan ship straight to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's
slash mintmobile.com caught your
wireless build of 15 beans a month
mintmobile.com
let's go kim let's talk about sofi
got a lot of bozos out there acting like
they know what's going on with myself
included how to do this how to do that
leave it to the professionals go to sofi
all right it's investment platform it
does everything you got the etfs you got
the crypto you got the whole nine yards
over there it's a one-stop shop now let
me was this a place you got to go or
something no you dummy it's a goddamn
app you downloaded the phone you're
making millions in 20 minutes yeah uh no
guaranteed uh me and a big man signed up
we are not only the
customers we're the player president
uh no commissions on trading stocks and
efts plus no account fees or hidden fees
use fractional shares that started as
low as five bucks to buy brand name
stocks even if you don't have a couple
grand laying around you get in the game
i got all my money in twix uh
complimentary financial planners are
ready to help you with any questions
whether you're stuck or on where to
start or need help deciding what to do
next safe for retirement with
traditional roth and even sep ira shout
out to phil x
uh explore the world of cryptocurrency
alongside the rest of your investments
uh 30 available coins including bitcoin
every
ethereum cardano solana dodge coins
salami they got it all a little bit of
pesto
uh cut through the jargon and make the
inves investing easier with so far visit
sofi.com garbage to learn how you can
win up to a thousand dollars in stock
when you open an account that's
sofisofi.com
garbage broker brokerage and active
investing products offered through sofi
securities llc remember f i n r a
slash s i p c
dune you'll clean it up
back to the show i think i may
i got out clean though so i don't know
how to say it if it's true but like i
feel the pull whenever i play again but
poker like when i got
into gambling yeah but i have a gambling
i have a very unhealthy relationship
you still bet sports no i stopped
getting sports but poke i mean we used
to do poker black if i'm in a casino and
we're gambling yeah yeah he stinks i can
tell you that
not stinks
not stinks and cards but he gets on a he
gets in
he becomes a person that i'd never seen
before you because first of all he
doesn't i stink in casinos
this is this i want everybody to rob the
joint this is his version of me stinking
at a casino meanwhile it's real focused
yeah we're gamble there's money on the
line dude
see see there's ten peop the fact that
you spin this is crazy there's ten
people at a [ __ ] roulette table or a
blackjack we're all having fun one of
them was homeless by the way he was he
was stealing
[Laughter]
he's acting like he's the like the feds
are coming what are you doing let's see
let's go let's go let's let's go let's
go let's go up to the room
make me nervous i'm like meanwhile
there's ten of us in a casino gamble
that's what we're doing yeah i mean and
you could rip butts yeah no i was
chainsmoking i'm gonna go get a drink
get the [ __ ] out of here like if you
don't want to be here baseball coach in
the 70s but don't ruin everybody else's
time where's that he boxes you out if
you're saying it don't shut up dude i am
enjoying got his rabbits today
we're here doing this this is why okay
what are you doing don't [ __ ] crack
me look at my cards
it chokes me oh yeah
then he hits me and says i can't read
because he hits me at the table
i'm just yelling at you but especially
i mean let me surmise my i got i got off
track a little bit you stink to hang out
with in social settings
one-on-one i know you're all right in a
car not too cheap casinos make me
nervous i always feel like somebody's
tailing me yeah
he literally
panic why i don't know here's the thing
that's probably a healthy way to feel in
a casino because i mean like this is
simple i was on mushrooms in a casino
and if you do want to stare the
blackness of humanity in the eye
you do hallucinogens in a [ __ ] casino
i have done them on multiple occasions
like we used to use this purposely
get them drive down to a casino and take
them just to trip the lights and stuff i
assume the noises the bells the whistles
it's no that's
all well and good it's that it's it's
like it's the desperation it's the
[ __ ] money changing hands it's the
clear advantage to them and like the
whole the this whole institution is
basically built to like pill for money
from the locals while kind of creating
whatever i i have no idea but that's
what i was seeing while on mushrooms and
it gave me a real bad vibe yeah we were
in a casino and i love casinos we were
in the casino a couple days ago i'm
looking around i'm like does anyone in
here look like a human being to you
because they really don't dude first of
all they look non-human the guy to
roulette table with us
was had a had a tape measure on his belt
like he was yeah on lunch break from a
construction job
he came to play the wheels he had his
nose
yeah oh i bet he was hitting too he was
on a bit of a heater i gotta give it to
him yeah instead of the nba logo a
casino logo should be somebody holding
an oxygen tank smoking a cigarette it's
crazy
just a way to outline with the double
dough
yeah it's a tough look um
all right this one's from will this is
not a question but i was at a concert
last weekend and a guy proposed during
the opener
[Laughter]
oh my god wait till the main act
the opener people are still milling
around they're like oh
i think you're in my secret that's
[ __ ] crazy proposing in front of some
local band what is the thought behind
that you didn't want to interrupt like
your favorite band maybe i i don't know
uh maybe they were their job maybe the
the opener was their favorite band
because i know people have done that
they're like yeah i don't care which
makes you even more of a loser
if you're a fanboy for the opener
no man because if she says no she
doesn't deserve to see queens of the
stone again
that's it we're leaving i'm gonna scalp
your ticket
beat it and then you do this to me in
front of goodbye charlotte you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i got one seat one ring 500.
yeah that's [ __ ] i so want to know
what band it was
how did you propose
uh i proposed in no better way than that
but i i it was my wife's statement
at least they were on stage
minor league soccer game dude this is
some absolute trash dog [ __ ] so water
skateboarding i mean
it said will you we're down
so i uh you know we we've been together
for a really long time my at this
forever high school sweethearts
elementary school like we lived next to
each other when we were ten dated in
fifth grade hugged you know all that
[ __ ] basically played basketball
together we're best friends growing up
sure dated throughout middle school in
high school it's a huge story
so
it you know it's her birthday we're like
seven or eight years in i forget how
long but at this point i am
anti-marriage i have bits about it i am
going hard in the paint against marriage
i think it's a dog [ __ ] institution i am
100 in on her and our life together
she's like that's great i'm so happy
deep down i knew she wanted to get
married of course so i i got the i got
my grandmother's ring
which is a give it to me old bag
i pulled it off her cold finger when her
finger was still on there
she fell asleep watching golden girls
it was literally right when she died
dude i got the ring and i'm like that's
still warm and i popped it right on my
wife but uh no so i get this uh
was your grandmother alive when you got
the ring no she had passed away she had
passed away i think like two years
earlier had that gone down the chain to
was it going to you it was it was kind
of so it actually it was a surprise it
was like a thing my s it was given to my
sister okay and my sister gave it to me
or she said hey this is kind of a this
is a beautiful ring it's like a 1940s
vintage diamond ring like beautiful and
she's like i know you're totally not
with it but if you were to ever
i think this would be a good ring was
your sister married at the time yeah i
think she was or maybe not because she
had she dated her husband for like 10 or
11 years before they got married yeah
he's a good sister yeah and we're both
just like you know we we saw what our
parents marriage was like so we both
took our time you take it yeah
i don't want that chicken
lord of the rings
i don't want that mask exactly so so i
actually i had like a change of heart i
think it was a it was actually a
mushroom trip that kind of brought me to
the decision and then uh and then i
so i come home from syracuse i think i
did syracuse funny boon with funny bone
with distefano and i bought her a bunch
of shitty syracuse orangeman gifts
because that's where she went to college
and that was her birthday present so i
presented her with awful gifts and she
was like
you know all right disappointed whatever
then i took her to gary veeder's show
the irish exit sure up there in the
upper east yeah for her birthday watch
me on a free good show oh you stay i get
bumped by four comedians like che
neil brennan i forget whoever else the
[ __ ] are you doing this all in
anticipation to set her up for the yeah
so i'm gonna propose like i
intentionally was like setting low
expectations for the night
[Laughter]
i was working on new stuff
i could have killed but i wanted to make
the light special they were actually i
think they were gonna they were gonna
put somebody else up again and i
literally had to go to the person it was
like hey i'm about to propose to my girl
can i please [ __ ] go up on the show
so i can leave and get dinner so
i get up by the time i get up the
restaurant we were going to closed
so we can't even go to dinner we then
drive take a taxi all the way back to
crowdsource are you bombing and then
deceiving yourself will you marry me you
propose to her on stage no no no i would
never do that um that would be so you
just did your set and left yeah did my
set and left i had the set anyway but i
you know that was just a little it's
just a little detour we had to take
because if she's getting a ring
i gotta make eight bucks
i gotta get the hat right
beer
so uh we we end up taking a cab back to
crown heights we're arguing in the cab
and we finally like there's no
restaurants open we find a restaurant
it's nice enough we we eat there
whatever we go back to our apartment
it's like 11 45 at this point she i
pick a fight with her about doing the
cat litter like like scooping the cat
like her turn or whatever and so we're
like kind of arguing both like kind of
busting each other's balls like it's a
whole thing and she comes into the
kitchen with like a pound like a 30
pound bag of cat [ __ ] and i'm on my knee
with the ring
and that's when i proposed to her ah
yeah look at that
catch it in hand catch it in hand
what'd she do with the cat [ __ ] dropped
it everywhere
so you're supposed to freeze that
i got to tell you opening band doesn't
sound that bad no no you win
how about an open mic on the upper east
side
it was a good bar
show
there was a photographer there
i had to look cool on social media
that's [ __ ] great uh this one's from
saul your parents ever make you get out
of the car at a long intersection like
to hit the crosswalk button so you can
hit so you can get the green light
faster the crosswalk button's trash
let it play out
how much of a rush are you in that's for
blind people and [ __ ] what are you doing
that's [ __ ] nuts no wild no yeah i've
had parents get i've had my mom get out
of the car from arguing with my dad and
walking like on the side of the road oh
yeah yeah that's happened where she's
like i [ __ ] had it slam the door gets
out like walks the opposite direction on
my way that was fun
that's bru i remember my parents
whoever was driving crashed
that's insane
what do you do scoop around and get her
yeah yeah i mean
no
yeah of course no i was like leave the
[ __ ] we don't need her we don't need
her dead wait hello yeah hello
applebee's we're going to be three
tonight frankly she's been bumming me
out
thank god
some ass
just push your sister out of the car
[Laughter]
dudes only
i remember whoever was driving
when we pulled up to uh
uh a train crossing if the things were
down somebody would get out whoever
adult was in the front seat would get
out and go and look to see if a train
was coming and if not
whoa no that's like you don't do that
that's nuts i had a friend die from
trying to beat a train
i never understood i'm just breaking the
heat
that's playing the hits baby
yeah he saw it coming and tried i don't
know if he saw it coming there's dispute
about how it happened but yeah i guess
i don't know that would be a tough one
to try to beat if it was that close i
would never take that chance i don't
understand that but i think there was
something in the that said the like sun
was at an angle where like truly blinded
him like 100 percent vision gone and he
just yeah
that's [ __ ] but the things down
though
yeah yeah i think he might have he
popped through him or something it's
like dude i've never seen those things
be wrong
right
i have i have i've seen him go down and
then back up
and nothing came through okay sure but
one
in a yeah
five million
it's like dude just wait the 30 minutes
yeah yeah but unless you do this and
then like cut back
turn to get you're not supposed to be
there yeah
yeah that's bad i think i've done that
though like like when i was like when i
was a kid and reckless and [ __ ] like
that 100 percent i definitely took
chances like that i never did
yeah you ever drop a drawbridge
whatever drop a drop what is this road
trip
do you ever have to jump a school bus
for the blind
i don't have to torch your dad's car
just to get back so your girlfriend
didn't know you were cheating on her
they could make it back in time for the
test jump a drawbridge uh i have not
have you ever
did you see those kids jumped that tesla
not too long ago yeah didn't it explode
you got [ __ ] up in
san francisco they like hit
like like one of those streets and this
thing went [ __ ] airborne the
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah and then they were
just like a stolen car i assume
i think because they tracked the
somehow tracked the tesla with like the
gps or whatever like whoever it was
those things are wired to the [ __ ]
hard to steal i would assume how do you
steal a tesla any [ __ ] comcast remote
turns it on
[Laughter]
it's all right
it's all right
[Music]
all right this one's uh from luigi f
baby
you ever have a teacher take your desk
and move it so you're sitting by
yourself against a wall for bad behavior
relentlessly yeah yeah that was probably
your zone yeah and i got taken uh also
desk outside the door that was big
like the secretary
mr johnson's not taking any meetings
right now
excuse me do you have an appointment
yeah but that would be the easiest way
to cheat on a quiz yeah is that you just
write on little like little things on
the little fold up paper and then you
have it out there and the teacher's not
even looking i was a big fan of the four
together when you were a little pop pods
were all
i felt like i built my own home with
textbooks also you ever do that where
you just like me oh yeah the enclosure
yeah you feel safe just [ __ ] people
in the back there
nobody look at canada
[Laughter]
i don't know why i'm getting this vibe
from you did you ever put tax on
someone's seat no no no no i didn't do
[ __ ] like that i wasn't a bully i was
just disruptive yeah like
wildly yeah looking for laughs like we
were joe i mean joe pull a fire alarm
no never did that i wasn't like that
there was a couple kids like that that
were like more jackass style high jinks
you know [ __ ] like that and who
trying to get my rap career off the
ground okay i dosed my principal once
dude i don't know if this like probably
could get me in trouble but when i was
15. i talked about it in public why not
we were i was 15 so i don't know how
like and i was talking to a teacher but
i
said my i told my teacher who was like
young 30 something i was like your ass
shakes when you write on the board
when i was like 15 years old was it a
girl or a guy it was a girl oh but it
was like crazy that style did you think
you could still get in trouble for that
is that i don't know it's not great
people are digging up stuff from 20
years
because she said that to you
yeah no i've seen her since we're cool
we're cool man she's cool she's cool
she knows what's up she knows the deal
helping me you know find my voice
she leaves you like shake it for me one
more time
i hate to see you leave love to watch
you go
the most dirt ball line in the world i'm
gonna sit right here and enjoy the view
do you have a taped over your uh your
cam yeah good for you uh-huh boy well
yeah
it's also one of those things
that if i put it i'm very i have obvious
i have very bad anxiety and i've
lived my life in a way of like if i can
limit the thought of
i don't think it's on i don't think
anybody's hacked it sure but in my head
if i see it and it's looking at i go
that might be
that could be on you know
awesome we were doing the zooms
right right like it was most it's not
for the [ __ ] cia hacking me it was
for like we're on and off zoom calls for
like you're doing [ __ ] all these
podcasts doing the quarantine i'm like
[ __ ] seal her up yeah you know what i
found myself doing sometimes is like
i'll i'll like catch myself just making
eye contact with the webcam out of
nowhere remembering that it exists and
be like i [ __ ] dare you yeah like
just talk [ __ ] do it [ __ ] what are
you looking at
what try to get just open my [ __ ] and
show it like i hope you enjoy
it's like [ __ ] american pie
i'm talking to the three gans three
three guys outside in a van right now
with the headsets on
have a good look
[Laughter]
i'll
i like the rhythm of it you were my only
friend on that one
you're my only friend he's a good guy
that kid is a polite gentleman
um [ __ ] what were you just talking about
the disruptive behavior fully stinking
desk in the back outside when you got to
take a test
yeah i lost it yeah
it happened
but there was something the question was
the kid in the desk did you guys get
sent out a lot i got in trouble yeah i
was uh yeah in trouble a good amount for
sure definitely ghost in the hallway
yeah yeah [ __ ] whatever i remember
one time was when like rap got big like
jay-z dmx i was in sixth grade and i
wrote all the lyrics
uh to
including all of oh yeah words on my
desk and pencil
and like
he had saw me do he like let us do that
like the original white kid manifesto
yeah
it was just like dmx it was like you
know stop drop open up shop whatever i
was [ __ ]
and he found it and was like what the
[ __ ] is this dude he's like you gotta
take this [ __ ] off right i was like oh
my bad i thought we were cool
i thought we were [ __ ] [ __ ] hard
bro
you're smoking a blunt
[Laughter]
[Music]
i was always like good enough to like
i'll give you a feature on my next album
play it cool uh that's another question
i've asked before do you know the lyrics
to the eight-mile rap battles yeah oh
yeah everyone that was right and the
whole soundtrack yeah yeah that is uh
that's a top three live movie experience
of my life i saw it i saw it on opening
saturday in a jam-packed movie theater
and it felt like we were in the shelter
yeah like people were just like
like just
the energy of that light and people
literally like like vibing like this
like in the shelter and i'm just like
literally just ready to go some they'll
tell these people something they don't
know about me ah
people were nuts it was ballistic yeah
it was [ __ ] awesome
you ever seen that movie dork
i saw it a little bit i didn't see the
whole thing i don't think you didn't go
to the theater no no i was like 38 when
i came out
get my [ __ ] ass kicked what are you
talking about
walking i got a do-rag on
[ __ ] out of me wearing it about baby
blue where's this kid's parents
[Laughter]
dude you and a do-rag would look sick
he's got his own mom's spaghetti with
him i used to wear i wore one my best
friend uh they all wore wave caps yeah
right
and he had my best friend rodney when i
was growing up and he had an older
brother andre that was
literally the coolest [ __ ] guy
in that part of pennsylvania like that's
how [ __ ] cool he was he always had
you know the coolest things first he was
a great athlete he was cool as [ __ ] and
they used to always wear wave caps on
during the day when we'd be sitting
there playing nintendo and his cousin
used to show up in the summer he was
[ __ ] the coolest guy in south
carolina they were like just two of the
coolest dudes so i wanted to feel like
them so the three of them would be
sitting there with their wave caps on
and i would [ __ ] put one on and they
would be okay with it but when their dad
came home he used to freak out
they're like hey what's this that white
boy
i swear to god he had this caribbean
actually everything henry take that
goddamn thing
get in the car we're going to get pizza
oh my god that's awesome just chilling
there playing excite bikes like what's
up that is the best yeah i uh i i got
cornrows once when i was in college uh i
went sandals
yeah this was uh not sandals i had a
classic identity crisis when like you
know my family was like splitting up all
the [ __ ] was going on at the same time
so i just like i went full the opposite
way i had all my teammates were black
from the city i immersed myself in that
world i had like at first i had the tape
up with the lineup i wore
xxx long white tees with pele pele they
were hot at the time white on white air
force ones we're talking about like 2004
yeah yeah exactly 2003 2004.
i even changed my uh my like
voice a little bit like it it
took on an affect
dude my friends were coming home from
college like what happened to you dude
what happened like my parents are
breaking up
oh what's been going on buddy has school
treating your mind
mike
and then the next year i grew my hair
out and uh
this girl gave me braids give me
cornrows wow yeah would you wear the
headband with the brush i had to wear
the do-rag to sleep to keep it in and
obviously my hair isn't built for it and
she was like pulling it out trying to
get as much of it out as possible and so
it was the most painful experience of my
life it was like dude it was crazy
and then i'm doing the like the
the tap tap itch because everything's
itching and if you itch it it pops out
like [ __ ] bed springs
like that and one mixtape lied to me
you stink come on justin timberlake
didn't look like this at the vmas
[Laughter]
oh that's right [ __ ]
he had that was that time things were
real wonky at that time yeah early 2000s
yes yeah yeah i tried some things on
some of that stuff needed to be
straightened out a little bit yeah
you're right i used to do the jersey
with the matching fitted oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
mitchell and s was big so you're like
you know huge yeah it was bad there's a
couple of bad pics floating around with
a 5950 [ __ ] new era of flap room
cooking with this sticker
[Laughter]
you stinking
take the one off the top the circle 59
50 new errors i would take that off but
you always left the hologram
i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] i kept both i
was a dual sticker
hachimachi
all right let's do one or two more and
then you gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
he really lets you breathe in between
the questions nothing makes me nervous
there's that fun paranoia
it's a good hang right in fairness he's
like watching sandy hook videos right
before the right before toby yells
actually body cam footage of my rack
you literally hear animals screaming in
the background of the videos i'm like
how you doing over there buddy he's like
ready to go
what i'm fine
got some spots tonight huh what are you
doing
it's been a weird one i like it
okay
let's take a long pregnant pause here
wait canon so you're telling me you
don't want to bring that to a casino
with you yeah
i would like to just uh just to kind of
get the vibe i understand why you yeah
it's no fun yeah yeah
it's being on my boys from high school
like slapping five having fun and he's
like yeah go back to the room yeah
let's get the [ __ ] out of here let's go
to a bar dude too many people go to the
vending machine and go back to the room
for three hours
i think this guy's following me i'm
gonna hide i'm gonna hide by the ice
machine for a little bit what are you
[ __ ] john nash from a beautiful mind
that's what it's like i'm like here's
henry foley ladies and gentlemen
oh man that was it was such a dude i
went
it was like he was on he was like
sweating like we gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here dude
it was like a bulldog it was because it
was like in the morning it was like a
wednesday there was a homeless guy
literally stealing these aren't the
things it was about one o'clock on a
saturday
it was after our show
okay there was still a homeless guy
there with foam coming out of his mouth
i won't argue that we weren't at the
nicest
you make it sound like i was
embarrassing you at the borgata or
something like that we were in a bad
place
[Laughter]
one guy was playing with buttons what
are you talking about
excuse me do buttons play sir
this card protector was a syringe
sorry you can't use monopoly pieces i'm
sorry
god damn it
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
dude thank you for doing that though
because mine was a [ __ ] and that was a
diarrhea that was
that was awesome so that was a couple
seconds slower
i would have walked away from that
accident
god damn it
[ __ ]
let's just wrap it up
buddy we absolutely love you i love you
guys go check out the [ __ ] special
yeah please check
youtube.comcomedy white privilege
homeless
comment like all that stuff just tickle
the algorithms balls for the love of god
he's one of the best we love the
everybody out there loves you again go
and check it out i don't know the homies
are watching yeah yeah i don't know get
in that chat
you know drop your own sad story
talk about your parents divorce
i'll come to your house and weird it up
a little bit for you
gary we love you we'll see you next week
peace
he always gets called his hand in the
cookie chart
oh that was the best